if you just somebody who want the
regular wings you regular get some
regular wings and then just say yo you
know let me get 110 piece of those limit
let me just see what's cracking and take
them home and then you don't say nothing
let your girl Trump and then you will
see thank me later
you could be on me tweet me I'm trippin
they always do it as Atlanta goes so
goes the nation the songs the slang the
fashion the dances is all here and lemon
pepper wings are just another part of
the ACL wave I'm here I'm hungry so
pucker up because in this wing town
lemon pepper is king we literally have a
wing spinal every [ __ ] corner in oil
and it's legendary it's like part of the
culture you walk around Atlanta streets
for you know a couple days you'll start
seeing just wing bones they're all over
the place you have to get lemon pepper
wings high is good barbecue teas and for
lemon pepper is the bar high this
probably little wings but the pepper is
the Kelly
it's a chicken wing coated in a really
zesty really lemony tangy sauce
complemented by a black pepper you get
sweet you get sour just enough tangy to
where you know it hits you you're not
seeing squeezed lemons and pepper dashed
on it it's a butter sauce and they're
tossing it in it you put them in a
bucket we put a little bit of butter to
it to get them wet or if you want them
dry rub we'll just sprinkle the lemon
pepper on that lemon pepper wet all
flats like who are you hearing that from
why you gonna still cook let me get to
it flat strip clubs got like the best
wings
I'm keeping the party going one way
[Music]
a lot of people come here to magic
cities obviously for the ass me I'm here
for the wings but it's funny because I'm
not the only one who comes here for the
wings you're just joining the club right
now you and you involved like I say you
see what's going on behind us this is
the show you're coming here for that
show this is this is the open acting
good luck if you think that's like
sketchy they like Howie Nicki girls and
the food must be sus of course what got
in the food you know are you always in
there but like if you were to go to a
strip club and the food was trash that
would be really offensive to you as
absolutely but you wouldn't find out in
the land Oh like the steel clubs and
they'll ever have literally the best
food that's not I'm not even
exaggerating about it and everybody in
the city knows that you know I'm here
getting wings on that cheetah getting
steak on that
no blue flame getting salmon from chef
tails and Tails kitchen right this day
Atlanta way this is what we do every
single day
[Music]
you liable to run into the biggest
rapper in the city the A&R from Def Jam
and our menace cope without writing the
Coach K and amigos and my city area
right next to let me go the way that a
strip club kind of sets the tone and
sets trends in music in Atlanta is it
any surprise to you that it's also
setting a trend when it comes to food
when it comes to blend a couple and the
lemon couple of things started because
what we started doing was getting hot
wings and putting the lemon peppers
sprinkling on on the hot wings to break
up him oh that was the way that we kind
of gotten so just fully just eat lemon
peppers like you know we're try to have
something burning your teeth the trick
is you got hot sauce all over and
getting stuff all over your white it's
not sexy your swag you know it's running
you're tearing up the last thing you
want to do is such a chick shaker hand
pulling out money digging in your pocket
with hot sauce the lemon pepper wing is
kind of like a perfect strip club over
the cult of lemon pepper is strong in
Atlanta's legendary strip clubs but this
special seasoning has evangelists all
over the city namely its homegrown
wrapped superstars as much as you hear
lemon pepper and rap lyrics you would
think that it was a luxury car or a
clothing line
[Music]
lemon pepper wings and lemons it's like
a peach what happened to you it's like
white boys and Crocs you just [ __ ] that
were you gonna do it's like wearing
khaki you love khaki
welcome to you [ __ ] out there
as lemon peppers brother if you eat
chicken you never had a lemon pepper we
slap the churches right now I mean like
Ares getting single heat and [ __ ]
jail crickets in sofia that was my
specialty order 150 wings well you say
limit pepper a goddamn year huh hey you
got some leftover huh okay it's raw so
at this point you are more than just an
artist a mogul a label CEO but you're a
winged God you're the next Colonel your
thirst
you're running a winged Empire tell me
how many wing stops do you own right now
somewhere around 30 you know as a
youngster coming up I just you know I
enjoy it whatever we was enjoying but
once I tried lemon pepper wings it was
just unique it was different the zing of
lemon just imagine pepper I was just
like yo dis for me like whatever your
favorite thing is you have ever eaten
that's what that is for me it's real
easy rose they said they was the best
Wayne's going buy some [ __ ] lemon
pepper wings the oral history of Atlanta
is always told through hip hop whether
it's lyrics about local landmarks
fashion trends new slang or now the
city's favorite flavor wings my boy
Maurice garland is an encyclopedia of
all that so we went to his hip-hop
trivia night that he hosts with Brandon
Peters to see if local fans know their
lemon pepper facts
[Music]
hip-hop is a branding machine hip-hop
has always been about name dropping and
claiming something I feel like lemon
pepper wings is now hip hop's the first
time I heard somebody just like
specifically put it in a song there's
probably like you know gucci mane
lemonade song with some about you know
lemon pepper wind breeze cook I mean
obviously the up teen times that Rick
Ross's mentioned it you know saying like
even before he was owning wings thought
restaurants it was like this is
obviously this man's favorite food you
know but Flo Hina tried to sell it to me
he was obviously even the hell out of
this thing but with Rob's me of course
he's gonna say he has the best but I
convinced money there's gonna be a lot
of people that strongly disagreed with
that statement wings top is no obviously
a very successful franchise but at the
same time like it is a franchise
sometimes when you build today who is
spot you're like man JJ was in a
good-ass movie today no it wouldn't put
me Wayans you know that we asked you to
name the restaurant The Paperboy and
Darius got lemon pepper wet wings from
on the TV show Atlanta that is junior
crickets mostly I got there right it
feels like the lemon pepper cult kind of
came to a head during that episode of it
when they had the scene right here in
chair cricket when you saw the pre piece
for Atlanta you didn't really know what
it was about you know is it gonna
authentically cover this Atlanta culture
on this like national scale and then
right off the bat in the second episode
they open up this box of wings and
they're flowing and you remember life
that's how you feel about lemon pepper
wings if you're from here so Stephen
Glover which is Donald lovers brother
yeah he was one of the writers in the
episode and he said that he kind of
created the episode to blend the best of
both worlds from Jennifer Gibbs and
Americans le so American Deli is known
for their lemon pepper wet style and
jerry' pricketts is just known as like
the Buffalo killer when I saw Donald
Glover scene in FX's Atlanta I
immediately thought number one hey I
don't remember that being on jackets
menu but at the time like lemon pepper
wet is something just before me it's
like something super specific that you
wouldn't get anywhere else it can only
have been an American deli that he found
that that term particular term I'm in
pepper away we never asked like what's
your order gonna be when you go to
America deli after school it without
revealing lemon pepper that was just it
it's like a litmus test okay that you
all like are you Atlanta
[Music]
we just caught the glow of that jr.
crickets lemon pepper wet and now I
understand how Paperboy felt in that
episode of Atlanta but there's so many
different favorites in the city and I
asked my boyfriend Burt a proud Atlanta
native to gather his friends to eat
ultimate Maine showdown
I was like hey what if I call on my
friends from home and we go to the
backyard and we get wings from five
different places and then we do a little
blind taste test these are all semi wind
snobs that eat a lot of wings love their
wings but more importantly love Atlanta
there are five places and they're kind
of spread all over like geographically
kind of the type of wings
lt's is like the southside staple jay
our crickets is like the famous one
there's Duggan's american deli and then
wing stop okay everyone take a wing and
have an opinion
are you all in agreement about flats
versus drugs your kid you want a [ __ ]
drum when you grow up you want some
class I'm wearing I'm going to a gala
right does everyone know proper like
flat technique yeah they're like the
rock
[Music]
why do you know that salties because
Logan look at the love that was there's
some more lemony than peppery they
should be more peppery than limiting
we're about to unveil okay this is Jake
[Music]
this is somebody's first foray into
little pepper wave it's a mature
response well I tried that shot at Rick
Ross let's just like take a little which
one is the best one but are we are we
buying we buy low what I'm saying is
like to blow up is it gonna be like a
Taco Bell shell flavor lemon pepper
right should we get out now and remember
these good times that we have but what
we've gathered from this taste test is
that all wings are not created equal but
that I mean this is just the universal
magnet that brings a lot of people
together here in Atlanta no true or
false Trump mmm Quinn
[Music]
we didn't invent these wings like it's
not like the only people that use these
spices but somehow like this dish fell
into our lap and we got really excited
about it and we're like this nice music
is different here and it's popping right
now put it in hooded unhooded
I don't understand nothing they saying
but I like the beat and it look good in
a strip club with a container full of
chicken wings next to it 6:11 pepper
with some fries this life every time I
walk into the store it's like the first
time hoping to get some lemon pepper
yeah I see you big boy I take whole
platters the next day there sit down
throw them out let us pitbulls eat them
even they eat little pepper wings you
know people from the deal for you come
down here say uh-uh you're gonna
cheesesteak playing a whack you know
first punch of Kabul comes it
oh you're deep-dish Pizza prisons are
whack but like with wings right now this
are [ __ ] for us
lemon pepper wings are Atlanta it
doesn't matter how we started it matters
way Atlanta do life they got it so level
created thank you
[Music]